l' enquête sur la disparition de la
petite estelle mouzin est elle relancée
après un an et demi d'investigations
sans résultat sept personnes ont été
interpellées dont un homme qui habitait
guermantes et a déménagé après la
diffusion d'un portrait robot mois de
juin il a été placé en garde à vue à
compiègne philippe castel philippe
hernando sur cette couverture une des
sept personnes interpellées par la
police judiciaire de versailles
peut-être le principal suspect hier soir
vers 18 heures les enquêteurs qui
travaillent sur la disparition d'estelle
mouzin perquisitionnent cette résidence
secondaire de mire en cours d'emploi il
y interpellent un homme de 34 ans ce
matin des fouilles sont même entreprise
dans le jardin au total six personnes de
l'entourage du témoin principal sont
emmenés par la police dont la femme qui
prétend t il ya un an elle l'a hébergé
ici à gauche
un village qui se situe juste à côté de
guermantes
là où a disparu estelle mouzin le 9
janvier 2003 mais soudain l'homme des
ménages en juin dernier lorsqu'à
portrait robot est dressé par la police
judiciaire de versailles
les policiers se rendent compte en
décembre 2003 lors d'une rafle sur une
centaine de pédophiles que lui il manque
à l'appel
ce n'est pas vraiment un pédophile
d'ailleurs il n'a jamais été condamné
mais seulement soupçonnés en 2002
d'attouchements sur ses neveux et nièces
les policiers le retrouvent finalement
il y a quelques jours à muirancourt dans
l'oise m'avait dit qu'il était heureux
une dispute avec ses parents et qu'il
était muni se met en colère ici aux
policiers il déclare en fait qu'il s'est
mis au vert parce qu'il devait une
importante somme d'argent à des dealers
de cannabis de seine et marne
il était d'ailleurs lui même connu des
services de police pour cela et c'est
peut-être à ce titre et non pas en tant
que suspect dans la disparition
d'estelle mouzin que sa garde à vue
pourrait être prolongé d'ailleurs selon
des témoins le portrait robot ne lui
ressemble pas du tout et la personne
était quand même assez le thème de ma
taille environ un peu trapu et blonde
plus ou moins blanche frisée et qui ne
correspond pas du tout par trop beau
ce soir le procureur de la république de
mou qui devait tenir une conférence de
presse l'a annulée se bornant à préciser
qu'il ne fallait tirer aucune conclusion
hâtive